مع وجود عدد قياسي من الأشخاص الذين يموتون بسبب
المواد الأفيونية، فإن أول ترياق
لعكس الجرعات الزائدة على وشك أن يكون
متاحًا بدون وصفة طبية، وسنبدأ في
الحصول على النالوكسون في متجرنا في
الخامس من سبتمبر، وفي الوقت نفسه
سنجعل النالوكسون متاحًا
يقول كبير المسؤولين الطبيين في Walgreens عبر الإنترنت إن الأمر سيستغرق بضعة أيام حتى يصبح
النالوكسون معروفًا باسم العلامة التجارية norcan
في جميع متاجرهم، وسيتم بيع الدواء أيضًا
في المتاجر وعلى الإنترنت في Rite Aid
Walmart وCVS، ولديه
سعر تجزئة مقترح قدره  44.99 لكل كرتونة من
جرعتين، لا نريد حقًا أن يكون هناك
أي وصمة عار، لذلك جعلنا هذا
متاحًا في الواجهة الأمامية للمتجر
فوق المكتب ولكن أيضًا في النهاية الخلفية
للمتجر بالقرب من الصيدلية المواد
الأفيونية  الأزمة ناجمة عن
عقاقير اصطناعية قوية مثل الفنتانيل،
ناركان هو نسخة رذاذ الأنف من
النالوكسون ويمكن أن ينعش الشخص من
جرعة زائدة في دقائق، ويقول الدكتور ترينت هول في
مركز ويكسنر الطبي بولاية أوهايو إنه من
السهل
استخدام الخطوة الأولى للتحقق من
خطوة الاستيقاظ.  اثنان
يعطون الجرعة الأولى من ناركان
الخطوة الثالثة
اتصلوا برقم 911
الخطوة الرابعة راقبوا وأعطيوا المزيد كل دقيقتين
إلى ثلاث دقائق حتى يستيقظ الشخص
وأنا ماندي ديف أيضًا